at the beginning of the film a man opens
a door and to his shock he finds a world
10 years behind our Earth there are
inverted buildings high-tech cars and
Technology a million times more advanced
than any other world it turns out when
God created the universe he created 22
parallel worlds for an experiment some
of those worlds are miserable with only
war and suffering While others are
normal then there are the worlds with
advanced technology and happier people
humans from all the worlds have no idea
about the existence of the parallel
worlds except for The Gatekeepers they
are the supernatural beings tasked with
checking the people who go through the
interworld travel and one of them is
kiril but before he was anything like
that he was just an ordinary person
originally he was a person from our
Earth the scene shifts to a few days ago
hero returns home from work and to his
surprise there is an unknown woman in
his apartment the woman introduces
herself as Rina before kiril demands to
know what she's doing there he wants her
to immediately get out of his house but
to his shock the woman claims that the
house belongs to her this puzzles and
infuriates KIRO causing the two to get
into an argument soon the police are
called Carol finally gets to enter the
property but to his utter shock the
whole house has been changed from the
inside and his neighbors also don't
recognize him Rina brings out some
paperwork and proves that the house
belongs to her eventually the police
tell kiril to leave the property and he
reluctantly agrees dejected kiril
returns to his office with his friend
for a work party it's revealed that he
has recently designed a successful game
and thanks to it Hero's company has
secured a new business deal kiro's
bosses are very happy with him and they
let him know that they appreciate his
work and what he has done for the
company when he returns home this is
when he meets the strange woman unable
to prove his ownership KIRO leaves and
goes to his friend katya's house he
explains his ordeal to the guy while
looking up his property papers on the
internet after collecting evidence of
everything he takes it to the National
cooperation the following day just when
he thinks the confusion is about to be
solved he learns that the government
office doesn't have any record of his
name in the office's database kierol
then goes to his office to look for
proof of ownership but no one seems to
recognize him even the people who were
praising him the night before for
creating the game Furious kiril creates
a scene in his office and has to be
kicked out soon he turns to his friend
Katya as he is the only person who still
recognizes him Katya is also confused by
what's happening to KIRO and suggests he
meet his parents to confirm his identity
kiril goes to meet his father but to his
disappointment even he refuses to
recognize him claiming that he doesn't
have any children upset Carol decides to
confront Rina the woman that seemingly
started it all he barges into his former
home and again asks her to leave this
naturally turns into an argument and
kiril threatens her with a knife Rina
remains unfazed as she strangely makes
Carol point the knife to her stomach
Carol thinks she is trying to scare him
but is surprised when she actually stabs
herself in the stomach as Carol tries to
make sense of what just happened Rina
dies soon the police arrive and arrest
kiril on the charge of murdering Rina
the scene finally Cuts back to the
present strangely enough instead of
taking Carol to the police station the
police let him walk away without filing
any charges he then receives a text
message on his phone instructing him to
go to a nearby Lighthouse because he is
stranded in the street at night he
decides to follow the instructions the
lighthouse is in shambles and Carol
spends the night inside of it the
following day when he wakes up he finds
the lighthouse as good as new he also
discovers that the scenery outside the
lighthouse has changed as if he has
somehow teleported to a new place
overnight next a courier appears from a
door with a bunch of books and from
another door Rina enters the place Kira
is stunned as he is under the impression
that Rina had died the woman orders
kiril to receive the Courier before
telling him that he is in another world
a new world that is parallel to his she
reveals that the name of this world is
the same as his video game this is when
we find out that when Carol designed his
game he inadvertently create created a
gateway to another world Rena then shows
kiril the whole world from a door and it
looks just like kiro's world she tells
him that now that he has created the
portal he must live in his new world
Rina has made his existence Easier by
removing kiro's identity from his world
and making everyone forget him she also
reveals that there are thousands of
other worlds that are parallel to one
another the gates to some have already
been opened While others are yet
unopened Rina and people she knows
recruit humans with special powers who
have the ability to open doors to other
universes and kiril is one of them only
a select few people are aware of the
existence of the parallel worlds and
they travel to and fro between different
worlds through a tower called The
Traveler kierol asks her how she knows
all this and what her real identity is
to this Rina replies that she is not a
human but a super entity and KIRO has
also become like her along with his
superpowers kiril now has the power to
manifest things he desires inside his
Tower he he has been made a customs
officer and is supposed to examine
people traveling from different worlds
to the world that he manifested through
the video game she orders him to read
the book The Courier man delivered
earlier to familiarize himself with his
powers and duties Carol refuses to
accept all of this and insists on
returning back to his former World Rina
who expected him to act this way warns
him that in his world no one will ever
recognize him again moreover he is
nothing more than a criminal and will be
arrested for her murder if he returns
after Arena leaves kiril invites Katya
to his Tower and explains what happened
to him as Katya tries to make sense of
everything Travelers begin to arrive
kiro's former girlfriend also arrives
with her date Anton who is revealed to
be a super entity Anna recognizes Katya
but she doesn't seem to recognize KIRO a
day before Carol was forgotten in his
world he was surprising his girlfriend
Anna outside her home while Katya was
filming them however Anna was upset
because Carol hardly made time for her
and was always busy working moreover
Kiro also forgot that Anna's birthday
was the day before Anna refused to give
him another chance and ended their
relationship back in the present hero
approves Anna and Anton's travel with a
heavy heart and the pair leave minutes
later KIRO decides to follow them with
Katya to see where the couple goes
unfortunately the two come under attack
by a doll-shaped robot trying to stop
them this gives Carol an opportunity to
use his superpower and easily defeats
the robot in the same building KIRO
comes across a dying woman named Rosa
she desperately pleads for water and
kiril quickly fetches her some after
drinking the water Rose's wounds
instantly heal and she recovers she then
reveals that in this world water is a
Healer of any and all disease even if
someone is dying and they drink water
they will instantly recover Rosa also
turns out to be a customs officer who
came to this world when she was 27 years
old and has since then stopped aging and
has become immortal after chatting with
her for a while Carol returns to the
Tower and falls asleep when he wakes up
he learns that another portal is opened
overnight and he is entered a new and
beautiful Universe hero decides to go
out and explore the beach right outside
his Tower soon Rina and the Secret
Society members arrive to inspect this
newly unlocked World Reena gives kiril a
locket and tells him that from now on he
can only go out 15 kilometers from his
Tower if he tries walking beyond that
point he could die after Arena and the
others leave kiril decides to go and
meet his parents who are 13 kilometers
away from the tower he knows the risks
of walking that far but takes it anyway
on the train to his parents house he
drifts away from the tower and as a
result kiro's body becomes weaker as he
desperately becomes thirsty a man offers
him water which recovers him in an
instant after reaching his parents home
kiril pretends to be his father's
student and has dinner with them later
he returns to his Tower and there Anna
and Anton show up again it turns out
Anna learned about the newly unlocked
World which has a beautiful beach that
she wanted to visit as Anna checks at
the beach kiril exploits his position as
a customs officer to find out that Anton
on is not dating Anna and he is just a
man hired by the secret society to keep
an eye on her Carol is finally relieved
and he again tries to woo Anna it's
revealed that Carol managed to open the
door to the latest world because he was
thinking of Anna Who Loved beaches the
two spent some time together which leads
kiril to take Anna to a party thrown by
Rina this leads to rina's displeasure as
she too has a crush on KIRO at the party
Rosa entertains Alex while KIRO meets a
man named Felix who happens to be a
former Customs officer of this world
Felix reveals that he got expelled from
his job because he opened the gates to
many new worlds without the approval of
the secret society Felix also reveals
that there's a world called Utopia which
rules over all the other worlds it's the
only world where people of other worlds
cannot travel to Meanwhile seeing Carol
busy with others Anna gets upset and
quietly leaves the party however she
gets kidnapped by Arena's henchman and
is dropped off to another world to
ensure she never meets KIRO again KIRO
on the other hand starts looking for
Anna the party and after failing to
locate her he returns to the tower there
a member of the committee surprises him
and secretly assigns him to a task to
open a door to Utopia where no one is
allowed to go she claims that Utopia is
the real world and all other worlds are
merely copies of it in Utopia there's no
hatred intolerance or disease there
people live happily and in peace the
Committee Member wants Carol to find out
the secret of the real world's success
so that other worlds can learn from them
kiril accepts the mission but he is
still concerned about Anna the next day
he looks up Anna's house on the map and
it's 15 kilometers away from the tower
he knows going that far from the tower
will kill him but he doesn't care as
long as he gets to meet his love
expectedly his condition deteriorates as
he approaches her home but to keep
himself from dying he eats the snow he
eventually makes it to her home but is
disappointed when he doesn't find her
there at last he returns to the tower
where he notices that entry to another
world has opened this one's seems like a
dystopian Gulag with impoverished
civilians there everyone works for a
factory that is owned by a woman who is
revealed to be the world's custom
officer when she learns that Carol is a
customs officer from another world she
asks him to deliver a speech to motivate
her workers Carol agrees and in the
crowd he notices Anna who appears to be
weak it turns out that rina's henchmen
abandoned Anna in this world knowing
that the Customs officer would never let
Anna walk away KIRO cleverly crowds her
with her own workers and proceeds to run
away with Anna they are chased but
eventually managed to get back to the
lighthouse a while later Katya arrives
at the Lighthouse and it's revealed that
he is also a secret society member this
is also the reason he didn't lose his
memory when everyone else in Carol's
World forgot him upset with kiril for
bringing Anna Back From Another World Ka
irreduces kiro's walking limit to a mere
50 meters from the tower after Katya
leaves Anna's health deteriorates so he
takes her to her dream world Anna Begins
to recover but past 50 meters Hero's
Health rapidly deteriorates as he almost
passes away Anna pulls off the locket
from kiro's neck that Rina had given him
when he first arrived the two then
returned to the Tower and the next day
the door to another world opens this
time it's the utopian world that is
beautiful technologically advanced and
has no flaws hero meets the world's
Customs officer who tells him that this
world is the original one and is 10
years behind the other worlds those
worlds were created so that the people
from this world could predict what could
happen in the future and prevent
anything bad from happening the utopian
World actively learns from the mistakes
of the other worlds if War breaks out
and won this world avoids all things
that caused the War the same thing
happens if a disease breaks out or an
apocalypse occurs in the other worlds
similarly if a new invention is made in
the parallel world this world instantly
copies that technology so they still
have Twitter they're doomed shocked by
the Revelation kiril decides to return
to the tower but the officer refuses to
let him return alive now that he knows
the utopian world's secret many entities
from the Utopia try to kill him but he
somehow manages to return to the tower
there Rina confronts him and it's
revealed that she again sent Anna to
another world this enrages kiril and he
attacks Rina a long fight ensues which
ends when kiril kills her as she dies
kiro's world begins to collapse with her
death the people's memories return and
Carol's mother contacts him and requests
that he return home Katya then appears
and informs him that the tower has been
broken so they cannot travel to another
world again kiril seeks kaiya's help in
finding an alternate Gateway and after
the two leave a fire brigade puts out
the fire at the ruins of the tower
consequently Rina survives and the movie
ends hinting towards a sequel subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching